one of the things we do on YouTube is we
are trying to take 8 hours of research
and put it into an 8-minute video well
the only way to do that is if you master
and learn the law of Simplicity I think
one of the biggest mistakes that content
creators can make is they think that
just because of good editing or good
lighting they're entitled to viewership
and entitled to people caring the better
approach is the opposite approach you
know that I don't recommend starting a
podcast I recommend starting a video
podcast because of the visual element
could you level up your video with
b-roll with supplemental clips and
footage with drawings with props with
animation this book is the cheat code
for creating better content it's packed
with practical tips for Content creators
and in this episode of the think media
podcast we're going to be looking at
some practical tips including 10 ways to
immediately improve your videos and get
more views three powerful laws of
communication and how to apply them why
your current videos are not getting
views and how to fix them and then tips
for mastering the ultimate skill for
building a personal brand and a
profitable online business the book is
the 16 undeniable laws of communication
by John Maxwell and I read it so you
ultimately don't have to but of course
if you want to check it out on audio or
the physical book we'll link it up in
the description down below but why is
communication so important well
according to Harvard Business review the
top Criterion for professional
advancement is effective communication I
think we realize that essentially what
YouTube videos are are communication if
you're going to be on camera or even if
you're not on camera with a faceless
Channel if you improve as a communicator
your videos will improve Warren Buffett
emphasizes the value of honing
communication skills for personal and
Prof professional growth and he talks
about that as being the Peak Skill
necessary for earning more and so today
we're going to cover three of the 16
laws and some tactical tips underneath
each of those and again if you want to
check them all out pick up the book
number one the law of content this
states that when we have something worth
saying people will listen I think one of
the biggest mistakes that content
creators can make is they think that
just because of good editing or good
lighting or just because they make a
video
they're entitled to viewership and
entitled to people caring I think that
the better approach is the opposite
approach we should feel like we are not
entitled to views not entitled to
subscribers not entitled to people's
attention and that we have to earn it
that we have to work for it that we
actually have to come up with something
that is worth saying and I mentioned 10
ways to immediately improve your videos
this law is packed full of practical
tips and here are a few great
communicators Bridge the success Gap and
relate to Their audience one of the most
powerful things you can do in your
videos is understand that people want to
know about your struggle before they are
open to learning from your success
videos that just brag or just talk about
the result without the struggle fall
flat from making a true connection with
viewers hopefully on YouTube if you are
sharing an answer to a problem if you're
helping people reach their goals you're
not just telling them the solution by
the way that will please people and
there's no reason you can't get views
from that but if you want to strengthen
your content you want to bridge the
success Gap are you articulating your
struggle think about it when you hear a
public speaker if all they get up on
stage and do is brag about how
successful they are it actually builds a
wall but if at first they relate that
they've been there they've struggled
they've also been through the process
and through pain and trial and hardship
they have found a solution and now they
want to share that solution with you if
you can weave that into your content
it'll be more powerful start any message
by understanding your audience's
perspective here's the question before
you sit down and outline your video do
you truly understand who your audience
is do you truly understand their
feelings emotions needs we say it think
media the Creator who understands the
viewer best wins so if you're going to
start a video you want to understand
your audience's desires perspective
point of view beliefs and the big
mistake is 99% of content creators don't
even know who they're making content for
and even if they think they do a lot of
times there's a disconnect in that area
identify and operate within your
strength zones for credibility it's a
good content tip if you try to create
content about something you're not
strong at you're going to lose to
somebody who's stronger at that content
personally I try to stay in my Lane
there's a lot of things where I'm happy
to go on a video podcast and be
interviewed about and there's many
things where I have no clue about when I
think about my strength zones if you
want to talk about YouTube let's go if
you want to talk about business let's go
marketing let's go if you want to talk
about the Bible let's go if you want to
talk about politics I don't know if you
want to talk about pop culture I kind of
know I'm not going to go work at
BuzzFeed I'm not going to go work at TMZ
those are not my strength zones or my
passion zones and so you're going to
have maximum credibility when you
operate within your strength Zone have a
clear thesis for your message it's the
core of communication are you starting
each video with a clear thesis and one
of the things I loved about this book is
again I was thinking about how it
applied to YouTube videos but you don't
hear a lot of people using that language
which it reminded me being back in
English class in high school I was like
that's true a video should have a clear
thesis it should have a core to its
communication and are you trying to
communicate too many things in one video
is the point unclear in the video is
your communication generally foggy
Clarity is power so do you have a clear
thesis another Point here is research is
crucial both for specific talks and for
continued personal growth one of the
ways to power up your content is to
improve your research so how can you
invest more in research develop your
skill of research and I liked that John
highlighted the benefit of it not just
being powerful for the content itself
but also helpful for your continual
growth one of the things I love about
doing this podcast one of the things I
love because I actually am passionate
about YouTube and video marketing and
social media is I've created a job that
I enjoy doing meaning I like to research
about YouTube but when I do I get
smarter and I grow my knowledge and I
include that in videos and you get to
benefit and I get stronger hopefully the
content get gets better it's cool to be
in a position where the the the
monetization loop is helpful to fund
being able to do this full-time and I
know that that's also what your
aspiration is as well in your particular
area but I want to encourage you the
development of the skill of research and
the inclusion of good resarch search in
your content will make it stronger
outlining provides a structure for your
message can you outline your videos
numbering your points or using pneumonic
devices can make your message memorable
can you number your points that's why
we're doing three points today as well
by the way and a lot of times I like to
outline and have numbers so they
structure to the content and then
pneumonic devices could be something
like in our Tech episode we talked about
AVL audio video lighting May maybe your
points are connected to a framework of
some kind in fact we're going to talk
about the four hes the four primary
connection points of communication in
just a second it's four hes it's kind of
a pneumonic device that John created
that we'll touch in just a second craft
messages using research illustrations
and stories from your own life there's a
couple ways to power things up and I
love this every message is like an
airplane flight requiring a successful
takeoff and Landing good takeoffs can be
built using questions quotes connections
while Landings should summarize and
empower the audience now there is an old
joke here on the podcast and at think
media that I'm always Landing the plane
and that I'm you know uh taxing to the
uh to the the terminal and that we're
stuck on the tarmac and that we're
circling the airport and this joke that
I can't land the plane but every message
is like an airplane flight and those are
some powerful tips for hooks can you
open with a question can you open with a
powerful quote can you open by making
some kind of connection of course the
goal in communication is to connect with
the viewer here on YouTube and so we've
already covered a lot and we have two
full more laws to go through and the
four primary connection points but
here's a summary of the bullets I just
hit can you relate in your content do
you understand your audience's
perspective can you play to your
strength zones do you have a clear
thesis are you doing your research do
you have a good outline for your content
are you numbering your points can you
include illustrations can you include
stories and every communication is like
an airplane flight there's 10 little
nuggets under the law of content and
before we go to the next law here's the
four primary connection points of
communication heart help humor and hope
and so it's crucial to identify and Lead
With Your Best connecting strength so
which of these four is your strongest
heart this means genuine heartfelt
communication based on EMP empathy and
authenticity I think we can all improve
our content this is a cheat code for
Content creators if your videos can be
more authentic and you're not faking it
you're comfortable in your own skin you
figured out your own voice when you've
got empathy for the viewer and that's
communicated through the camera when
you're speaking from the heart and
you're being genuine and this might take
some time to develop not only in the
skill of communication but getting
aligned with the topics you're covering
with your channel topic heart is a
superpower and for some of us that might
be your primary superpower for others it
might be a little bit more weak uh more
of a weakness so let me know if that's
yours help involves offering practical
advice and tools for change this is
probably one that I lean to I want to
develop them all but I am obsessed with
crafting content that's actually helpful
that's value based that anwers specific
questions that solves specific problems
humor is about seeing the lighter side
of life and connecting through laughter
if you have a gift of humor that's a
power ful way to improve your content
hope entails showing future
possibilities inspiring belief in a
better future maybe some people you
watch because you feel encouraged after
strengthened after your purpose in
watching is to get your mind right your
motivation up to get your mood shifted
your emotions charged and so four
elements heart help humor and hope one
of those is probably your strongest but
if you improve even more marginally all
four and have a heartfelt message that
solves someone's problem that makes them
laugh in the process and that ends with
giving them hope talk about a powerful
message a powerful YouTube video now
let's hit the other two laws but if you
watch the YouTube version of the podcast
smash like and rate and review on audio
but let's hit number two the law of
Simplicity the law of Simplicity
Einstein suggested that if you can't
explain something simply you might not
understand it well enough so effective
simple communication requires
significant effort it's easier to be
verbose than to be concise the reason I
wanted to include this law is I actually
think that this is one of the ultimate
opportunities for YouTube content
creators hey we're about to get back
into the podcast in just a second but I
have a question for you do you want to
grow your personal brand this year do
you need more leads and sales in your
business if the answer is yes then right
now is the best time to go all in on
YouTube Today's podcast is brought to
you by thanm masterclass.com where you
can get OnDemand access to a onehour
deep dive training revealing how to
start and grow a profitable YouTube
channel this year for a limited time you
can get access to this on demand class
entirely for free where you will learn
the three biggest mistakes that people
make when starting a YouTube channel the
new rules and and changes that have been
happening on YouTube and how you can use
them to create an unfair advantage and
the exact strategy we use at think media
to generate over
350,000 organic views every single day
the data is clear 70% of viewers claim
that YouTube makes them more aware of
new brands so don't wait any longer to
start growing your brand and business
with YouTube just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to this no
fluff highly tactical free on demand
training that's think masterclass.com
one of the things we do on YouTube is we
are trying to make complex things simple
we are trying to take 8 hours of
research and put it into an 8 minute
video well the only way to do that is if
you master and learn the law of
Simplicity we're trying to take eight
years of experience and put it into a 45
minute longer form YouTube video or a
web class of some kind the only way you
do that is not by being more verbose and
more complex and adding more information
you actually do that effectively by
simplifying content down and a lot of
the channels review and a lot of the
channels I review or the creators that I
give feedback to struggle because
they're overc communicating they're
adding too much information a lot of
times their content is full of too much
data not enough story they have not
distilled down the content and according
to Einstein if you can't explain
something simply you got to work harder
you might not understand it well enough
so I really emphasized and it stood out
to me that John maxw was like effective
simple communication requires
significant effort if you think this is
hard good because it is and the reason
you'll be rewarded with views and
subscribers and channel growth is
because you did something really hard
you processed and you thought and you
wrote it and you rewrote it and when you
when it wasn't quite quite clear you
kept working until the clarity was
tangible you're like well that's very
complex and I found a simple way to
communicate that also remember that the
most effective
messaging when it comes
to the internet social media this is one
of the points Clarity be should be the
first goal if an eighth grader can't
understand and explain your message it
isn't simple enough law of simplicity so
you're going to see bigger growth on
your YouTube channel if you've been
communicating maybe at a too complex
level 10th grade 12th grade PhD well
there's a reason why it's not working at
a broad appeal level because if you're
an eth grader can't understand it then
make it simpler Clarity should be your
first goal and I love this quote from
woodro Wilson he was asked how long will
it take you to prepare to give a great
talk or a public speech and he said it
depends if I am to speak for 10 minutes
I need a week for Preparation if 15
minutes I need three days if a half an
hour two days if an hour I am ready
now let that sink
in if I am to speak for 10 minutes I
need a week for Preparation 10 minutes
is a YouTube video if I am to speak for
an hour I can do it right now one hour
is a live stream what's the point it's
crazy that this this quote was said
before YouTube existed it just speaks to
high quality
communication is challenging and if you
want to make 10 viral minutes of content
on YouTube imagine if you put a week
into that if you don't you understand
your message but you really aren't
refining it well hey let's go live right
now and just you know chat take 60
minutes to get the message across man
it's something powerful about that quote
that I think could apply to what it is
we are doing great communicators
prioritize simplifying complex ideas
Simplicity is the Hallmark of powerful
communication Winston Churchill and JFK
were praised for their clear and
Powerful speeches effective
communication is about conveying clear
powerful ideas CS Lewis emphasized
translating thoughts into accessible
language suggesting that if you can't
your thoughts may be confused so can you
translate your complex topic or
difficult to understand topic into
everyday accessible
language and if you can't maybe you need
to work harder to distill your thoughts
into more accessible communication
especially if you want broader appeal
and bigger impact on YouTube brevity is
crucial impactful statements often
require fewer words like the Lord's
Prayer or the Gettysburg Address short
speeches often require more preparation
effective communication is about concise
impactful content not length John M's
law of Simplicity stresses the
importance of focusing communication
remove the unnecessary highlight the
essential imagine if on your next video
you removed the unnecessary and you
highlighted the essential practicing the
law of Simplicity and communication
means less is more and Clarity is power
John Maxwell suggests that we should
deliver messages simply slowly and with
a smile for effective communication of
course you have to have your own style
and you might say but Sean aren't we
doing jump cuts and talking crazy like
crazy YouTubers and I think that you've
got to understand your audience you've
got to understand your style of content
and different mediums require different
methods but there is something powerful
that if the content is Rich and
clear and specific and poignant that
sometimes slowing down doesn't mean that
you're going to lose the audience's
attention if the video is
boring if the video lacks substance if
the video lacks research well it doesn't
matter how fast or slow you go and so I
think there's something there as it
pertains to delivering your messages
simply slowly and with a smile for
effective communication and great
communicators turn complex topics into
simple Concepts all right so we're about
to get into law number three and I think
this one's actually my favorite but
before we do I want to remind you that
today's episode is brought to you by
think masterclass.com if you're
interested in taking your YouTube
channel to the next level or starting a
successful channel that gets views and
makes money in multiple ways I want to
encourage you we have a free 1our class
that's available on demand at think
masterclass.com actually depending on
when you're watching this I also teach
it live and we have a couple of those
live trainings coming up where I'm also
there for Q&A so check a link out to
that in into the description or go to
think masterclass.com all right the
first law we covered was the law of
content secondly was the law of
Simplicity and third is the law of
visual expression and those are not in
order in the book there's 16 laws in the
book I really can't emphasize enough
that this entire book will improve every
single YouTube content creator I know
that's a big endorsement but I totally
believe it the book is packed with tips
and hopefully this podcast is showing
you that truth the law of visual
expression states that showing and
telling is more impactful than just
telling and this is interesting while
voice only communication had its place
in radio's Heyday it's essential to
incorporate visual elements today the
next generation will receive 90% of
content on their phones visually not
verbally and around 60% of people are
visual Learners with images sticking
better in their memory than words now
this is exciting for us as YouTube
content creators and creating video
across social media platforms because
obviously that's a visual medium you
know that I don't recommend starting a
podcast I recommend starting a video
podcast because of the visual element
and shout out to everybody audio only
right now because of course that is
super relevant we're hanging out as you
walk or do walk your dog workout ear
pods the whole thing audiobooks podcasts
are a major major major opportunity but
of course YouTube is a visual platform
so here's a few tips visuals make
messages more memorable in a data
saturated Society images generate more
engagement and discussions with people
being highly responsive to them visual
stimuli engages the creative and
holistic parts of the brain shaping
future creators and empathizers now
think about this if you are visually on
screen that doesn't mean you're
including visuals in your video could
you level up your video with b-roll with
supplemental clips and footage with
drawings with props with animation and
maybe you can't do all of that right now
but could you dream a little bit bigger
about how you could teach educate and
entertain with your content the right
side of the brain is adept at processing
images synthesizing information and
seeing the bigger picture visuals
stimulate our imagination and can tell
stories better better than mere stats
and so a visual on screen showing some
data is one thing but could you also
show a picture of somebody that's been
impacted by the data a b-roll clip of
somebody that is the subject of your
story and here's some other practical
tips related to what could be done
visually body movement gestures and
facial expressions are crucial for
visual aids as a communicator if you are
just doing talking head video just
sitting down in a video podcast like
this how could you improve your
communication with body movement
gestures facial expressions the ambience
of the room lights up or down can
greatly impact the energy and focus of
the audience the lighting of your video
the nuances of the lighting the moods
you set can impact the energy and the
focus of your audience could that affect
audience retention and viewer retention
absolutely I think the quality of your
production your audio video and lighting
has an aspect that relates to viewer
retention which connects directly to
going viral and getting views effective
communication involves showing proving
and acting and not just speaking
metaphors and word pictures can vividly
illustrate Concepts and engage audiences
so here's a practical takeaway you're
planning out your next video You're
outlining the information tip one tip
two tip three could you go back through
and say what story could I include here
what metaphor could I include here or
word picture to illustrate this concept
or tip sometimes I like to share the
Bare Bones like I'm outlining in Google
Docs The Bare Bones of my YouTube video
of my video podcast and then I go back
through and say how could I power this
up could I put a story here and this is
interesting after a presentation 85%
remember visual content after 3 hours
but only 10% recall oral content after 3
days Steve Jobs presentation of the
first iPhone was impactful due to its
live demonstration top TED Talks use
visual aids from flip charts to
photographs but some people also don't
use any visuals at all and some of the
most viral TED Talks was pure words
communication voice tone stories humor
whatever they included which reveals
that you can have an effective message
without out visuals supporting it but we
also see that this is a powerful tool
that we can include in in our
Communications and a good practice is to
change the visual expression every 2
minutes to keep the audience's attention
now I think that John Maxwell is
applying this to the stage if we apply
that to the video I think you should
change the visuals a lot more often than
every two minutes we talk about every 7
Seconds every 5 to 7 seconds in a long
form video and those things visually
could include switching to a different
camera angle having text pop up on
screen and then think about all the
elements of your body movement and
behavior how visually engaging is the
video or how boring is the video b-roll
clips things that are changing and
shifting all of that can help keep the
audience his attention and when you do
YouTube rewards you with more views and
so I have a final quote to land the
plane on this episode but as a reminder
if you have not watched our free on
demand and YouTube class the next move
after this podcast is to check out think
masterclass.com there's a link in the
description down below um or in the show
notes for the podcast wherever you
listen check that out and it's totally
free 1 hour long and I really go through
the one strategy we're using right now
at think media I suppose we're applying
it over here on the think media podcast
Channel as well to generate around
400,000 views every single day so if
you're interested in that check outthink
masterclass.com also if you want to
check out the 16 undeniable laws of
communication John Maxwell is one of my
favorite authors his other books on
leadership predominantly are really
great for Business Leaders I think all
of us could grow as Leaders um but I
definitely would recommend that for
Content creators sharpening the skill of
communication will level up every single
aspect of your creator economy business
and so so we talk about a lot of good
books but this one that is directly
relevant and I think the audible is a
good move to make for listening well on
the go and then also if you're on
YouTube smash like if you're on audio if
you could rate and review the podcast
and I especially want to challenge you
if you're new here thanks for being here
I really appreciate your time if you've
been listening to the podcast more than
four episodes more than four weeks more
than four months if you've been here a
couple years and you haven't left review
especially you're listening right now
you're over on Apple and Spotify it
seriously would mean the world to me if
you rated the podcast reviewed the pro
podcast on Spotify you can give it a
star rating maybe some other forms of
reviews over there and that just helps
us get the world word out because we are
on a mission to help people become
better communicators through the medium
of video and if you've been experiencing
positive effects from your consumption
of think media content that is one thing
that would be deeply meaningful for me
especially during during this season and
I want to say thank you in advance and
thank you for every comment every like
every subscription every share that you
do it really means the world now let's
give you one final quote Robert Green is
the famous author of the book Mastery
and this is his quote about Mastery
Mastery is not a function of Genius or
Talent it is a function of time and
intense Focus applied to a particular
field of knowledge the encouraging thing
is you might right now say Sean I don't
feel like I'm a very good communicator
as you shared all these details I just
feel discouraged like there's an uphill
battle with so much to learn and I think
the encouragement when it comes to
Mastery is that Mastery is not a
function of Genius or talent and Robert
did some deep research of all these
different people that achieved Mastery
it's a function of time and intense
Focus applied to a particular area and
friend if you set your intention to
become a better Communicator to practice
rce to study to learn to read to listen
it's going to change everything it's
going to level up your videos it's going
to improve your relationships it's going
to make you a better leader and so
investing time into becoming a better
Communicator is time well spent